tarek skubal big fastball 6'3 215. he's
only 23 years old and so the 50th ranked
prospect that's pretty good a tim
anderson with his home run power at the
anderson household when he hits a home
run it's spaghetti night for dinner he
gets a big plate of spaghetti so he
loves the home runs tim in the air left
field it's time for a pasta party
cook it up throw in some meatballs one
nothing sucks tim got such a good look
at the first fastball there it is that
fastball is literally belt high middle
of the plate and gone
nice way to start i was thinking three
happy ones tonight there's one i mean
yeah it's got to be a little shocking
when you're used to striking everybody
out in the minors yeah the first guy you
face hits a home run against you two on
nobody out major league debut for tarik
skubal and i'd like to get out of this
first inning without any more damage
elohim is at the plate here comes on the
ground could be two beautiful scopes
turn in time that's what taric school
needed there so runners at the corner
with two down and here's james mccann
another 2-2
fly ball center field
jones drifting back at the warning track
at the wall when he's got it long first
inning for derek
righty on righty here
spoke as soon as he hits a fly ball left
center field way back and left center
and go on a home run
with a home run against season detroit
and now one in chicago we're tied at one
here in the second fifth of the year for
jonathan scope that's a mabel uh buggy
whip right there he got so much of that
looked like a hanging breaking ball and
it was also setting on it
that's the difference he was setting on
it one too many breaking balls and
jonathan did it again that's the boys on
the board and that's big time a great
time to be facing tim anderson by the
way no no no it's not
there's a dart to left field tim rolls
it all the way to the wall follow the
bouncing ball
one is all mizzara danny stops it third
ta's got himself an rbi double of the
sox retake the lead that's his first
driven in not on a homer this year
in the air right field
castro will have a play off monkatta and
he makes the catch mendic on his way
home tim hits third the sox get another
run and a completely needless throw
nearly brought home another one yeah
that didn't make a great deal of sense
because tim wasn't going anywhere and
you almost threw it by the tarp so yuan
drives in a run makes it a two-run
as game ball is golf to right field
castro charging he's not going to get
there rbi single jose abreu keep it
moving
another one home and the sox lead 4-1 oh
it hurts jose yeah that was right off
the end of the bat but
that 14th run driven in is going to
assuage his stingy hands he said at the
beginning but this was not a good time
to be facing the white sox lineup not
for a lefty certainly and not for a
lefty in his first major league start
and here is paredes
nico goodra
sends one to right mazara right where he
stands romine tags
and he will score there you go nico
goodram with a sacrifice fly the tigers
are within two derek skubal got his
first strikeout there and he got a big
double play when he needed one
through some good pitches through
something that i'm sure he's going to
regret
but all in all he was competing out
there and the first ones behind him now
i'm sure he'll take a lot of lessons
from it he'll relive this for a long
long time zay has a couple of hits he's
got a run driven home that was his 14
2-1
to right center field jacoby jones won't
get there over his head jose powers the
sox tim says come on along
throw to the play not in time to run
double top of the card seven for seven
extending the lead as he goes out and he
gets it and jones thought he was going
to make this play he didn't realize how
hard the ball was hit it accelerates
over his head and jose is having himself
a night 6-2 white sox and asked austin
romine coming to the plate
this ball is lined out
robert dives can't make the catch
oh he had he had it i mean i think he
feels he should have had it that was an
outstanding effort now did he hurt the
right hand is the key we'll slow it down
alex tosi on the call when the glove
hits the ground then there's no chance
for it and so it would have been a trap
anyway and hopefully he comes away
without injury luis robert had that dive
he stayed in the ball game at the moment
but luis gonzalez has checked in for
luis robert this is the major league
debut for luis gonzalez verdi had his
instructions from his pitching coach for
jacoby jones two on two away here in the
tigers eight
gets by mccann
willie castro will score
six three white sox yeah he catch a
break right there
here's the 2-2
pounded to center and out of the glove
misplay by luis gonzalez candelario will
score and jacoby jones gets thrown out
at second base base is loaded three
balls two strikes
big chopper left side of the infield
soto scrambles and safe at first
sox get a run keep the carousel moving
seven to four
tim scored three at the top of the
lineup jose abreu is driven in three in
the three spot heritage runners stranded
that'll be put to the test in a major
way
danny a drive
left center field stuart back jones back
and jones makes the catch mccann tags
and scores from third and the sox get
one more it is eight to four all right
what does tim have in his final act
tonight
tag to center that is smoked gonzalez to
score his first major league run ta's
got a fourth hit tonight
and it's 9-4 socks socks have created
some separation with three runs in the
eighth inning
diving play that's a fair ball
the recovery gets it out but the sox
pick up another run mazzara scores
candelario had it go off his body and
makata's hurt now
comes on to nail it shut
swinging a bit strike three and that
will do it the sox going away put up
double figures it started with a bang
tim anderson a home run to lead it off
and a 10-4 final for dylan cease and the
sox who have worn out lefty starters
dance your heart out tim anderson